We worked with multiplying monomials and binomials, and binomials with other
binomials, now let's try something a little bit harder. We're going to multiply
a binomial with a trinomial. Let's start with our simple case using numbers, and
then see if you can extend that to figure out something harder. Just like
before, we can split-up each of these numbers, so that way we can make this
multiplication problem more simple, I'll have 13, which is 10 plus 3, and 123,
which is 100 plus 20 plus 3. Now can imagine doing this multiplication using a
rectangle with the appropriate side-lengths. When I find the area of each of
these rectangles and add them up, I get 1,599, the answer to our multiplication
problem.